chérie mon âge alors c'est un arabe je
ferme mon taxi qui en juif qui arrivent
à l'aéroport donc il attend comme ça et
le joli ça arrive avec une petite
sacoche comme ça et il arriva pour
monter dans le taxi est pile au moment
où il va pour monter dans le taxi
il ya un arabe qui court comme ça qui
lui arrache sacoche et qui lui volent
ils voient les cours et où est le juif
idiot je fais un taxi attraper le
attraper la trappe et le chauffeur de
taxi sans roi des cons ils l'attrapent
il le massacrait le massacre ils
massacrent et le massacre et le massacre
et le jul dans la voiture écrit arrétez
arrétez arrétez et le chauffeur taxi
continue le massacre et le massacre de
massac le mec là la bouche en sang et
tous les juges dans taxi créé a été
arrêté arrêté le chauffeur de taxi
continue à massacrer le match ça qui
allait donc exploser à tout exploser
tout est retiré sa cage comme ça je lui
dis arrêtez arrêtez je vais attaques
s'ils arrêtent il prend et rod il
reprend un stage comme ça ils m'ont d'un
taxi des menaces et quand je lui concède
une prime dite arrêté alors que vous a
volé votre sacoche il dit arrêtez le
compteur
[Applaudissements]
alors dans ces conditions conditions
pour toi mon gars c'est en arabe revient
c'est ya mouloud et rachid ces deux
arabes
oui bien sûr au cateau au cas où tu
ferais pas mais sont sur le toit d'un
immeuble qui est ce qui saute en premier
l'immeuble
cette version cette version je n'aime
pas trop je préfère la version avec
marine le pen et jean luc mélenchon sont
tout comme ça je suis massacrés par tube
cathodique de bon michel pas dire oui
c'était laquelle la deuxième voiture
veut que continuer je vais me remercie
alors moi je n'ai eu sur l'insomnie pour
tous ceux qui souffrent un peu
d'insomnie le gala riche et surtout vive
il dit j'en peux plus j'ai essayé tous
les médocs
je dors maximum deux heures après je
suis réveillé thani c'est un cauchemar
et les toubibs il dit écoutez on a un
nouveau médicament mais c'est pas en
comprimés c'est un suppositoire site
d'ivry parfait alors il donne un
suppositoire essayer ça ce soir
et si vous avez bien dormez vous revenez
demain je vous prescris une boîte mais
qui revient le lendemain
edit docteur j'ai passé une nuit 8h pas
relever pour faire publie rien huit
heures d'affilée ça fait quinze ans que
ça mais pas rêver pied alors le suppo
l'efficacité [ __ ] c'est simple je me
suis réveillé ce matin j'avais encore le
doigt dans le cul
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une nana qui va chez son
sexologue elle se plaint levier voilà
mon mari chez il est en pleine crise la
plus gay bi do plus rien on fait plus
l'amour c'est terrible on a 50 ans voilà
on est chez moi je suis très très
malheureuse mais je n'ai pas très bien
comment lui dire d'écouter je vais
régler votre problème
je lui ai donné une petite gélules
aphrodisiaque et je vous promets que
votre mari va assurer sa du hainaut mais
jamais de la vie je pourrai jamais lui
arriver il prend même pas un cachet
d'aspirine y prend rien du tout il est
anti médicaments donc sais pas comment
je peux faire lui dit je vais vous
donner cette gélule vous l'a broyé vous
la casse et vous faites une toute petite
poudre comme ça et au moment où il va
dîner ou déjeuner vous saupoudrez son
plat à effet ok ok dakota dax d'accord
docteur et le temps passe et un jour
elle recroise les docteurs dans la rue
et il lui dit alors comment ça se passe
avec votre mari ça se passe bien a dit
oh là là pouvait pas savoir le soir même
où ma est donnée celle émise dans la
nourriture
il a fait valdinguer la tamim a prises
dans tous les sens sauvagement plusieurs
fois au docteur je ne sais pas comment
vous remercier c'était génial indien eh
bien voyez je vous l'avais dit je suis
vraiment content pour vous je vais oui
mais le problème c'est qu'on pourra plus
jamais retournés dans ce restaurant
une d'une jolie police
on en a besoin c'est un bus qui va à
lourdes il ya le chauffeur qui est là il
ya plein de vieilles dames à l'arrière
de vieilles personnes et un moment donné
le chauffeur il voit la vieille dame qui
arrivent et qui lui tend des cacahuètes
le chauffeur lui ça tombe bien je devais
m'arrêter j'ai une petite faim ils
mangent les cacahuètes puis cinq minutes
après la dame elle revient à weedon des
cacahuètes faut voir c'est gentiment
mérite dix minutes après elle revient
elle lui donne des cacahuètes ça dure
trois fois de suite et abandonner leurs
biens
il lui dit mais madame je sais pas vous
pourriez peut-être bien pour vos 40
copine derrière regarder les cacahuètes
et la dame al-jawf savez nous avec nos
dents les mns on aime que le chocolat
[Applaudissements]
sébastien est un imam un imam et un
rabbin ils montent dans l'avion
ouais ils sont assis l'un à côté de
l'autre et à la bagarre de l'imam fed et
moi toi tu cherchais un jus d'orange et
même que abane shirt orange alors alliée
la milice la ville puis y avait au bout
de l'avion il va chercher un jus
d'orange
pendant ce temps là le rabbin les
regarde les pompes de l'imam prend la
pompe y faire il crache - ben voilà ce à
quoi on est tous alors dit marié revient
il donne le jus d'orange ou tibaldi
orange extra extra qu'ils s'endorment
tout va bien matin leur avarice casse et
l'imam mis en garde sa pompe était
[ __ ]
bonsoir il a craché dans les chaussures
et oui tu vois les arabes et les juifs
qu'ils s'entendront jamais il a craché
les chaussures j'ai pissé en lui
d'orange
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]